Jetzt haben wir wirklich
das I-Wort in den Titel geschrieben.
"Aber es geht doch um die Impflicht."
Ja, aber guck mal,
wie's hier wieder aussieht.
Die ganzen Dislikes,
was da unten schon wieder
in den Kommentaren los ist.
Sag mal, könnt ihr euch nicht
mal woanders anschreien?
(Atemzug)
Wisst ihr was?
Macht doch, was ihr wollt.
Es ist jetzt auch grade zu wichtig,
um sich von so was
ablenken zu lassen.
Für alle, die Lust haben,
nicht emotional, sondern sachlich
über Impfungen und Impfpflicht
zu reden:
Ignoriert das da unten,
holt euch 'n Tee
macht es euch gemütlich -
wir steigen durch.
Ich war immer gegen Impfpflicht.
Für impfen, aber gegen Impfpflicht.
So ganz prinzipiell.
Denn warum sollte man Menschen
zu einer Entscheidung,
die ganz objektiv
die beste Wahl ist,
verpflichten müssen?
Viel besser ist doch
sorgfältige Aufklärung,
sodass Menschen freie, informierte
Entscheidungen treffen können.
Und Anreize schaffen mit Bratwurst,
ja, warum nicht?
Und Impfungen
leicht zugänglich machen.
Etwa beim Frankfurter Impf-Express,
'ne kostenlose S-Bahn,
in der man sich unkompliziert
beraten und impfen lassen kann.
Total super!
Und auch die 2G-Regelung scheint ja
Menschen zum Impfen zu bewegen.
Nur:
Was, wenn das alles nicht ausreicht?
Was, wenn weiter immer mehr Menschen
an COVID-19 sterben
und sich die Intensivstationen
füllen?
Ach, das passiert grade alle schon?
F***
"Es ist fünf nach zwölf."
(Christian Drosten:) "Wir sind einer
ziemlich schlechten Situation."
"Wir haben 15 Millionen Leute,
die eigentlich
hätten geimpft sein können,
und geimpft sein müssten."
Und wenn sich daran nichts ändert,
müssten wir uns
darauf vorbereiten ...
".. noch mindestens 100.000 Tote
in Deutschland zu bekommen,
bevor sich das Fahrwasser beruhigt."
"Und ich sage dazu:
Das ist eine konservative Schätzung."
Im Ernst, was machen wir jetzt?
Noch mal Geschäfte oder am besten
noch Schulen schließen?
Oder einfach Augen zu und durch?
Menschen sterben lassen
und wegschauen?
Oder ...
Gibt's noch irgendne Option?
"Wir könnten hoffen, dass
die Menschen sich impfen lassen."
Genau. Das wünsch ich mir dann
vom Weihnachtsmann.
Was, wenn all die Aufklärung,
die Anreize,
die niederschwelligen Angebote,
2G und das alles nicht ausreichen,
um die Impflücke zu schließen.
Kann man dann eine Impfpflicht
noch ausschließen?
Nein!
(entsetzt:) "Nein!"
Doch.
- "Ohh!"
Ganze ehrlich:
Ich verstehen die Aufregung
um die Impfpflicht nicht.
Und das als jemand,
der kein Fan von Impfpflicht ist.
Natürlich fänd ich's besser, wenn
die Menschen freiwillig und rational
die zweifellos beste Entscheidung
für sich treffen würden,
nämlich sich impfen lassen.
Aber wenn es
offensichtlich nicht passiert,
ist Impfpflicht
doch immer noch besser,
als das Virus mit uns
'ne Party schmeißen zu lassen.
Anders gesagt: 'ne Impfpflicht
wär jetzt nicht meine erste Wahl,
aber das kategorisch auszuschließen,
wie die Regierung
das momentan tut ... - "Klar: nein."
Ich versteh's nicht.
Ganz rational betrachtet ist eine
Impfpflicht sogar weniger krass
als die Gurtpflicht im Auto.
Denn der Sicherheitsgurt
schützt ja nur mich selbst.
Da könnte man ja noch argumentieren,
ist ja jeder selbst schuld,
wer sich nicht anschnallt.
Aber wer sich impfen lässt,
schützt ja nicht nur sich.
Da sich Geimpfte seltener anstecken,
können sie auch das Virus
seltener weitergeben.
Und Geimpfte haben eher mildere
Verläufe oder keine Symptome,
und wenn ich jemandem
ins Gesicht huste,
steck ich den auch eher an
als wenn ich keine Symptome habe.
Und leider stecken wir ja
nicht nur Leute an,
die sich gegen eine Impfung
entschieden haben,
sondern auch Geimpfte oder Kinder,
die noch
auch auf die Zulassung warten.
Wir reden nicht von Infektionen,
die man nicht vermeiden kann,
weil der Impfschutz
halt nicht 100 Prozent ist,
wir reden von Infektionen,
die ganz einfach vermeidbar wären,
wären alle geimpft.
Und all diese vermeidbaren
Infektionen sorgen gerade dafür,
dass unsere Intensivstationen,
die übrigens auch schon vor Corona
am Limit waren,
und deren Personal jetzt
seit über anderthalb Jahren Pandemie
mal so richtig am Arsch ist,
jetzt wieder volllaufen.
Und das zulasten aller Patienten,
die Intensiv-Care brauchen,
egal ob Coronapatientin
oder Unfallopfer.
Deswegen ist 'ne Impfpflicht
in besonderen Fällen gerechtfertigt.
Wie zum Beispiel 1959 bei den Pocken,
oder seit 2020 die Masernimpfpflicht
in Kitas und Schulen.
Vielleicht haben manche
den Ausnahmezustand,
in dem wir uns grade befinden,
immer noch nicht begriffen,
aber wenn eine Impfpflicht
gerechtfertigt wäre, dann jetzt!
Und es ist alles ganz rational.
Wir haben es hier
mit drei Fakten zu tun.
Nein, der Impfstoff
wurde zwar schnell,
aber nicht auf Kosten
von Sicherheit und Sorgfalt
entwickelt und zugelassen.
Nein, der Impfstoff
macht nicht unfruchtbar.
Nein, Impfungen sind keine
Belastung des Immunsystems,
Impfungen trainieren das Immunsystem,
ohne dass der Körper mit dem tat-
sächlichen Erreger konfrontiert ist.
Nein, Nebenwirkungen,
die erst viel später,
also 'n Jahr oder Jahre
nach der Impfung auftreten,
sind nicht zu befürchten.
Die Angst basiert anscheinend
auf dem Missverständnis
des Begriffs Langzeitnebenwirkungen
oder Langzeitschäden,
die in seltenen Fällen
tatsächlich auftreten können.
Darunter versteht man aber nicht
Nebenwirkungen,
die erst viel später auftreten,
sondern Nebenwirkungen,
die Tage bis Wochen nach der Impfung
entdeckt wurden,
die aber
langfristig bestehen blieben.
Ein Beispiel ist Pandemrix, ein
Impfstoff gegen die Schweinegrippe,
der in seltenen Fällen
Narkolepsie ausgelöst hatte.
Details könnt ihr in dem
extrem guten Blogartikel nachlesen,
den Lars aus unserem maiLab-Team hier
geschrieben hat.
Und was solche seltenen
Nebenwirkungen betrifft,
da sind ja vor allem die deutschen
Behörden hypervorsichtig.
Wir erinnern uns an das ganze
AstraZeneca-hin-und-her,
was viele verunsichert hat,
aber letztendlich nur
zwei Dinge gezeigt hat,
nämlich erstens,
auch sehr seltene Nebenwirkungen,
wie die Hirnvenenthrombosen,
werden entdeckt,
und zweitens, es wird auch
direkt darauf reagiert.
Und für alle, die sagen,
"die Impfstoffe sind mir
noch nicht gut genug untersucht":
Genau das Gegenteil ist der Fall.
"Fakt: Noch nie gab es Impfstoffe,
deren Sicherheit und Nebenwirkungen
nach der Zulassung
so sorgfältig beobachtet wurden
wie die Corona-Impfstoffe.
Einfach weil noch nie
Millionen von Menschen
in so kurzer Zeit geimpft wurden.
Das schafft eine nie dagewesene
statistische Power,
um sogar sehr seltene Nebenwirkungen
überhaupt erst zu bemerken.
Besser als das wird's nimmer, Leute.
Also mehr Daten
wird man nicht mehr haben.
Inzwischen sind ja schon
Milliarden von Menschen geimpft.
Und wer hofft, das Virus
vielleicht ganz zu vermeiden,
kann diese Hoffnung knicken.
Wir werden SARS-CoV-2
nicht ausrotten,
das Virus ist gekommen,
um zu bleiben.
Ihr werdet dem Virus
früher oder später begegnen.
Oder vielleicht auch
noch mal begegnen.
Und so wie die Infektionslage
grade in Deutschland wütet,
eher früher als später.
Die Frage ist nur,
ob ihr dann geimpft seid.
Das heißt, die Risikorechnung,
die man hier anstellen muss,
ist nicht zwischen
Impfung versus keine Impfung,
sondern zwischen Impfung versus
sich irgendwann ungeimpft anstecken,
früher oder später.
Und die Risiken einer Impfung
stehen in keinem Verhältnis
zu den Risiken einer Coronainfektion.
Wer also Angst vor eventuellen
sehr seltenen
Nebenwirkungen einer Impfung hat,
müsste sich konsequenterweise vor
Angst schreiend in die Hose machen
vor einer Coronainfektion.
Die man wie gesagt
auf jeden Fall bekommt.
Wenn man nicht geimpft ist.
Es ist so wie Angst zu haben,
dass man sich beim Anschnallen
im Auto den Finger einklemmen könnte,
oder dass der Sicherheitsgurt das
Schlüsselbein bricht bei 'nem Unfall,
aber keine Angst zu haben,
unangeschnallt aus dem Auto
zu fliegen und zu sterben.
Ja, man kann sich geimpft
auch noch anstecken,
man hat aber deutlich höhere Chancen
auf einen nur milden Verlauf.
Ja, man kann auch geimpft
einen schweren Verlauf haben,
das Risiko dafür
ist aber deutlich gesenkt.
Und ja, man kann geimpft
auch noch andere anstecken,
aber wie gesagt: seltener.
Wichtig ist, dass man
einen vollständigen Impfschutz hat.
Das heißt, nicht nur
die vollständigen zwei Impfungen,
sondern danach auch noch
die dritte Boosterimpfung.
Denn wie bei einigen
anderen Impfungen auch
verliert auch die Coronaimpfung
mit der Zeit an Wirkung.
Und bitte nicht irritieren lassen
von geimpften Coronapatienten
auf der Intensivstation.
Manche lässt das
fälschlicherweise glauben,
dass die Impfungen nicht wirken
oder nicht so gut wirken wie gedacht.
Die Impfungen
wirken so gut wie gedacht.
Die Anzahl der Geimpften
auf der Intensivstation
lässt sich
ganz einfach erklären dadurch,
dass inzwischen ja
sehr viel mehr Menschen geimpft sind
als nicht geimpft.
Und wenn irgendwann alle
geimpft sind, dann wären natürlich
auch alle Coronapatienten
auf der Intensivstation geimpft.
Aber natürlich kommen insgesamt
umso weniger ins Krankenhaus,
je mehr Menschen geimpft sind.
Wer daraus aber schließt,
Impfungen würden nix bringen,
müsste konsequenterweise
dann auch sagen,
"Sicherheitsgurte bringen nichts,
denn unter den
schwerverletzten Unfallopfern
waren 99 Prozent angeschnallt."
"Flügel bringen nichts, denn
bei 99 Prozent der Flugzeugabstürze
waren noch beide Flügel dran."
"Torwarte nützen nix, denn bei 99
Prozent der Tore war 'n Torwart da."
Ich kann nur noch mal unser Video
"So endet Corona" ans Herz legen,
da erklären wir den Unterschied
zwischen dem aktuell
gefährlichen Zustand der Pandemie
und dem, was danach kommt,
nämlich die Endemie.
Nach der Pandemie wird SARS-CoV-2
endemisch, also hier heimisch werden,
wird sich zu den anderen heimischen
Erkältungsviren hinzugesellen.
Doch keine Sorge,
man geht davon aus,
dass es dann
verhältnismäßig harmlos sein wird,
weil eben alle entweder geimpft sind
oder das Virus schon hatten,
das heißt, unser Immunsystem
kann was damit anfangen,
wir haben eine Grundimmunität
in der Bevölkerung.
Dass wir das Virus nicht ausrotten
können, ist also nicht schlimm.
Schlimm ist,
wenn wir auf dem Weg in die Endemie
Intensivaufenthalte
und Todesfälle zulassen,
die vermeidbar wären.
Das Ende der Pandemie ist in Sicht.
Bis dahin wird,
wer jetzt noch nicht geimpft ist,
noch mal: sich entweder impfen lassen
oder sich anstecken.
Wollen wir die Pandemie beenden,
indem wir einfach
mit den Schultern zucken
und die Infektionen laufen lassen?
Oder wollen wir alles dafür tun,
dass sich jetzt noch so viele
Menschen wie möglich impfen lassen,
und dass wir jetzt noch
auf den letzten Metern,
Leute, es ist Endspurt,
das schaffen wir jetzt auch noch,
Kontakte, die nicht notwendig sind,
vermeiden?
Also wir wollen Letzteres.
Nur dass das niemand falsch versteht.
Jetzt nicht denken,
jetzt ist's eh egal,
denn es ist nicht egal,
ob jetzt noch
Tausende Menschen sterben.
Wer diese drei Fakten verstanden hat,
kann nur zu einem einzigen
vernünftigen Schluss kommen:
Arm freimachen
und rein mit der Impfung!
Und mit der Boosterimpfung!
Nur wer die Fakten
nicht verstanden hat
oder von Desinformation
getäuscht wurde
entscheidet sich bewusst
gegen eine Impfung.
Natürlich ist keine Maßnahme perfekt.
Natürlich müsste man sich fragen,
wie eine Impfpflicht
konkret aussehen sollte,
also 'ne Impfpflicht für bestimmte
Berufsgruppe wäre gut überprüfbar,
eine Impfpflicht für alle
weniger gut.
Natürlich muss man auch
mit Dingen rechnen
wie gefälschte Impfzertifikate,
passiert ja jetzt auch schon
bei Testzertifikaten.
Das ist alles nicht optimal,
aber jetzt ist nicht die Zeit
für Perfektion.
Jetzt ist die Zeit für Pragmatismus.
Don't let perfect
be the enemy of good.
Lasst nicht "perfekt"
der Feind von "gut" sein.
Alles, was hilft, hilft.
Wir haben ja auch
gar keine Zeit für Perfektion.
Selbst wenn heute alle Ungeimpften
anfangen würden
mit ihrer ersten Impfung,
dann würd's ja noch Wochen dauern,
bis die volle Wirkung da ist.
Hätten wir
viel früher anfangen sollen? Ja.
Aber es ist noch nicht zu spät,
die Pandemie ist noch nicht vorbei,
besser jetzt als noch später.
Nervt es, dass wir deswegen immer
noch Kontakte einschränken müssen?
Ja. Aber besser als
volllaufende Intensivstationen.
Und liebe Regierung, ich weiß,
ihr habt versprochen,
es gibt keine Impfpflicht,
und ja, Wort brechen ist Scheiße,
aber wisst ihr,
was noch schlimmer ist?
In dieser Notsituation
NICHT euer Wort zu brechen.
Eure Begründung kann nicht mithalten
mit der aktuellen Notlage.
"Weil das, was wir im Land erleben,
eher dazu führen würde,
dass sich eine Spaltung
vertiefen würde,
und wenn man das
auf die Pflege bezieht,
eher dazu führen könnte,
dass mehr Pflegekräfte
den Beruf verlassen."
"Deswegen klar: nein."
Das ist jetzt
'n bisschen zynisch fast schon.
Pflegekräfte beklagen
jetzt schon seit vielen Jahren
die prekären Arbeitsbedingungen
und die schlechte Bezahlung
und versuchen verzweifelt,
die Aufmerksamkeit der Politik dafür
zu bekommen.
Aber jetzt macht ihr euch Sorgen,
dass sie aufhören. Okay.
Aber viel seltsamer find ich
das Argument mit der Spaltung.
Schaut in die Kommentare hier:
Die Gräben sind doch schon da.
Unter anderem, weil Menschen
wegen Desinformation
keine Fakten mehr erkennen.
Unter anderem, weil manche Menschen
ein "faires Freiheitsverständnis"
haben,
das nichts anderes ist
als purer Egoismus.
Und die zum Glück noch vernünftige
Mehrheit dieser Bevölkerung
wird momentan an die Grenzen
ihrer Fähigkeit zu Empathie
und Solidarität gebracht.
Denn Geimpfte
müssen sich grade einschränken
wegen Menschen, die die Impfung
und damit Fakten ablehnen.
Geimpfte müssen Angst haben
um sich und ihre Liebsten,
sollten sie
auf einer Intensivstation landen,
und sei es wegen eines Autounfalls,
dass dort voll ist.
Oder, schlimm genug,
dass das Personal überarbeitet ist,
weil dort Menschen
versorgt werden müssen,
die dort gar nicht sein müssten,
wären sie geimpft.
Wie soll das eine Gesellschaft
nach über anderthalb Jahren Pandemie
aushalten?
Die Spaltung entsteht doch nicht
durch Impfpflicht.
Sondern durch die Spaltung
in Geimpfte und Ungeimpfte.
Aber das ist jetzt nur
meine persönliche Sicht.
Viel wichtiger
sind die Fakten, nämlich:
Impfen ist sicher, Impfen schützt und
Impfen ist besser als nicht Impfen.
Sorry für alle Freunde der Sonne,
die das alles schon längst wissen,
ich wollte gar kein Coronavideo
mehr machen, weil alles gesagt ist.
Aber wenn auch nur ein Mensch von
diesem Video überzeugt werden kann,
könnte das ein gerettetes Leben sein.
In der Videobeschreibung
haben wir euch neben den Quellen
auch gut verständliche Erklärungen
für viele verbreitete Sorgen
gesammelt, die ihr so auch an Freunde
und Familie weiterleiten könnt.
Teilt das Video, helft uns einfach,
diese Info zu verbreiten.
Denn das einzige Mittel
gegen Desinformation
ist verlässliche Information.
Wir sehen uns bald, bis dahin:
Bleibt sicher. Cheers.